the second time they've exploited the
blitz of the pick and roll the opening
the first bucket and now that one
Looney and Curry play catch Curry
matches first three-pointer and his
first field goal brings a little more
size physical tough and according to
Mike Brown he's Fearless
curry ball Beauty from Steph Curry
[Applause]
struggles a bit with it and still
finishes lost his drip momentarily and
flipped it in off the glass
[Applause]
Curry long distance that's good
Steph Curry with his second three
and this is DeLisle that Center group
Curry left-handed lays it up and in
Davis has got to be more disciplined I
know you disagree but this is game seven
they don't have other scores
green trying to set a screen helps out
curry curry against Murray step back
three-pointers up it's good Steph Curry
with his third three-pointer
well the step back left
a little too much space But as Mark said
not much you can do there but when he
starts and then is able to pull back
it's just really difficult it's in the
floater is up and good and the Warriors
have tied it again
he's made the adjustments in traffic so
he was rushing early in this series much
more patient
tonight Curry and they have green
guardings of bonus to start the second
half Looney on Harrison Barnes
[Applause]
Murray pulls back gets face
number three five three-pointers now for
curry would have affected Steph Curry as
great as he was but look out and this is
a 6-9 Harrison Barnes he just eliminates
green fires Curry
hang on to that pivot foot scoop layup
is up it's good and a foul oh a circus
shot from Steph Curry and a chance for a
three-point play he had an amazement
just another spectacular play by Steph
Curry splits the double team Curry's
fakes fires Corner three no good trying
to slam it home Curry the rebound Curry
inside floats it up and in what a
sequence there for the Warriors no one
else is get coming up with the defensive
board and Steph and Curry sets it up a
6-8 rookie Keegan Murray guard and Curry
drives past him scoop lay up off the
class he's got which has been his
specialty all season
[Applause]
Curry against miles oh what a fake gets
inside again a layup is good
bonus is going to have to look for that
little mid-range jumper again
Curry mid-range jumper 36 points for
curry and the lead is a dozen oh good
going left look at the right show the
leans into the body just eliminating
monk enough to get to his spot in
elevator
the go with us 36 points and six assists
[Applause]
green hands it back
Curry the drive layup off the glass is
good box now with 16 points
green and curry curry drives past Davis
gets inside layup once again off the
glass
he's really gotten everything
he wanted tonight layups Beautiful
Finish
trying to swat it away
[Applause]
with Murray on him three-pointer puts it
in and then
the thing that only he can do
[Music]
beautiful dominant performance
by Curry Looney the rebound throws it
back up top to Green
Curry wants it
Murray harassing him Curry just flips it
up and in Steph Curry magic here in the
fourth quarter
just brilliant the Brilliance with Steph
Curry on full display here in an
elimination game
[Music]
team for 35.
[Applause]
six of 16 from three gets it back Curry
three-pointer bang Steph Curry is a goal
on the clock it's a touch pass to Steph
Curry a guy that's already
dominant all afternoon long
gets a look
just how ironic one of the worst Road
teams in the NBA during the regular
season will have the biggest road win of
the playoffs as Curry lays it up and in
a 50-point game seven for Steph Curry